it's crazy because
you and i have never met until recently
but i feel like we've been
in i mean i've been doing radio since
2005.
yeah and we've had mutual friends um
and it's just never and we never ran
into each other yeah and i think it
might is that i don't know man i never
really had a relationship with tyga
though
i think that i just never was like a a
big tiger guy
despite like
z that's why we never ran into your ass
it wasn't even that he was always hating
that i was never hating he was hating
dude just say he was hating him you have
this you
you he was hating dog okay
was nasty no we i wasn't a big tiger
fan like you was hating i wasn't hating
you was just one of the radio dudes that
was doing it it's okay your mind has
changed now
no my mind hasn't changed you [ __ ] with
them now i'm not no i mean i [ __ ] with
them every day i respect tiger i [ __ ]
with him you know i respect tyga do he
doing his thing and i and he's uh
probably the third greatest club artist
of all time damn
second future is one oh yeah number one
number two number two might be tiger man
number two
if we're talking about just songs you
could get off songs you can get off
right now and i'm talking like
i'm talking about like hip hop [ __ ] i'm
not talking about edm [ __ ] i'm talking
about like
little john's probably number two just
all around just gonna make any clubs
no a little john's number two man dennis
tiger now i'm talking about hip-hop like
a hit like you know what i'm saying like
yeah
i
i'm i'm pretty sure he'll take that
tiger skull
yeah i'm not a hater you went through a
whole run that that was beautiful i just
thought like last kings was just not
closed i would wear as a white dude i
told you i'd look crazy rocking that
[ __ ] why it's just
it's the golden oil at barrow head
it was like real you know technical you
know everything was detailed
it was some [ __ ] that i really would
actually put on but then we took the
brand to you know another level to where
we took it to tilly's and those the big
department stores we had to fill a
demand because once they felt like you
know and we had the first like cut and
soaked t-shirt ever to be in their store
everything else is like triple a
[ __ ] people printing on it right so
we had a you know cut and sold tv put a
design on it and it and it flew off the
roof
and then with those big stores when you
got about
2 000 stores and then you you have to
ship to all of these stores right right
right and they ordered order and that
[ __ ] the designs got to come out like
this
and i had this young white dude he was
white i don't know why he didn't wear it
his name was ryan you know what i'm
saying and that [ __ ] knew how to design
like up crazy like t-shirts like seasons
that she was coming out and i was like
damn so i just let him do his thing i
was making money and at that point i
just was like oh well [ __ ] it did you
[ __ ] with all the designs yourself no i
didn't i didn't but that [ __ ] was making
money so i didn't even give a [ __ ] i
didn't even look into it like that so
once your entire split up like who owns
the last king's copyright
um
that's that's why that's that's that was
the difficult thing about it that's what
we got sued copyright you know what i'm
saying and trademark infringement so at
that point was it death row that came at
y'all because you guys were banging that
death world last kings logo for a while
should should gave a blessing he did go
ahead you can have that you know what
i'm saying real quick you know what i'm
saying do the thing cool so we we rocked
it yeah but no just the pharaoh itself
though a lot of people wasn't it was
like [ __ ] i own it i own it i own it i
own it i own it so we could we try to
have a like a little distinct thing
about it which you know which made it
ours which it had a l and a k for the
nose and the mouth and people wasn't
feeling that [ __ ] yeah and when i said
we had mutual friends i mean in 2010 11
12 i'm in vegas at molly mall's house
all the [ __ ] time yeah uh
having some of the greatest nights of my
life and somehow
never ran into y'all there despite the
fact we was going crazy out there too a
hundred percent before we get into them
all you know i'm just [ __ ] happy to
be here you know what i'm saying i got
my glasses on my [ __ ] brother
hat i'm like
[ __ ] you only do big rappers and
[ __ ] that's like huge also i'm
like i'm huge